again last move doesn't exchange pieces  and uh no Trader Rooks White's attack  would suddenly die if you trade pieces  off so he steps back and  this looks winning moves The Rook across  one square Yep looks like game over  it is it is game over because I think  that uh Knight's days are numbers uh but  uh okay well Magnus being flashy he is  being flashy he don't care he's not  going to go straight for the kill he's  gonna grab as much material as possible  enjoy the journey they say yeah and he  took a Pawn on the Square the Knight  cannot take the White Queen because the  Knight is pinned uh Black's Knight is  pinned to its king it's uh it's illegal  unfortunately to come capture that white  queen and a big threat on the board of  actually playing Rook takes Knight I  think this is a killer actually yeah and  uh there we go I think Eric is he has  resigned facing a deadly attack from the  world number one wow what a start to the  final Magnus Carlsen he wins a dominant  game